in the video where i first introduced
the concept of entropy i just tried
something out i defined my change in
entropy
i defined my change in entropy is being
equal to the heat added to a system
divided by the temperature at which it
was added to the system and then i
tested to see if this was a valid state
variable and when i did that i looked at
the carnot cycle
i looked at the carnot cycle and this is
a bit of a review
never hurts to review let me draw the pv
diagram here we saw that okay we start
at this state here and then we
proceed isothermically we removed little
pebbles off the piston so we increased
the volume and lowered the pressure then
we proceed adiabatically where we
isolated things
where we isolated things we moved like
that
that was adiabatically
then at this other isotherm we added the
pebbles back so we added some pebbles
back
and then we kept and then we isolated
the system again so adiabatically we
continued to add more pebbles and we got
back to our original state
and i did a couple of videos where i
showed that if you take the heat added
here so this is all being done at some
high temperature t1 this is being done
at some low temperature t2 that there's
some heat being added here q1
and that there's some heat being
released here
q2 and since these are adiabatic there's
no transfer of heat to and from the
system and when i looked at this when i
looked at the carnot cycle and i used
this definition of entropy i saw that
the change in s
the total change in s when i go from
this point all the way around and got
back
the change in s
was equal to
q1
q1 over t1
plus
q2
over t2 and then i actually showed you
that this was equal to 0 which is
exactly the result that i wanted to see
because in order for this to be a state
variable in order for s
to be a state variable
it should not be dependent on how i got
there should only be dependent on my
state variables so even if i go on some
crazy path at the end of the day it
should get back to zero
but i did something i guess a little bit
it what i did wasn't a proof that this
is always a valid state variable it was
only a proof that it's a valid state
variable if we look at the carnot cycle
but it turns out that it was only valid
because the carnot cycle was reversible
and this is a
subtle but super important point and i
really should have clarified this on the
first video i guess i was too caught up
showing the proof of the carnot cycle to
put the reversibility there and and and
before i even show you why it has to be
reversible let me just review what
reversibility means now we know that
in order to even define a path here the
system has to be pretty close to
equilibrium the whole time that's the
whole reason why
throughout these videos i've been
drawing this piston you know had the
gases down here and then i'll have
always instead of having one big weight
on top that i took off or took on
because it would throw the system out of
equilibrium i did it in really small
increments i just moved grains of sand
and so that the system was always really
close to equilibrium and that's called
quasi-static and i've defined that
before
quasi-static
quasi-static and that means that you're
always in kind of a quasi-equilibrium so
your state variables are always defined
but that by itself does not give you
reversibility you have to be
quasi-static and frictionless
and frictionless
in order
to be
reversible now what do we mean by
frictionless well i i think you know
what frictionless means is that like to
see in this system right here
if i make this piston a little bit
bigger
that when this when this piston rubs
against the side of this wall
in kind of our real world there's always
a little bit of friction those molecules
start bumping against each other and
then they start making them vibrate so
they transfer some kinetic energy from
just by rubbing into each other they
start generating some kinetic energy or
some heat
so you normally have some heat generated
from friction
now if you have some heat generated from
friction when i remove a pebble when i
remove a pebble
first of all when i remove that first
pebble it might not even do anything
because it might not even overcome the
the you can kind of view it as the force
of friction let's say i remove some
pebbles and this thing moves up a little
bit
it moves up a little bit
but because some of the i guess you
could say the force differential the
pressure differential between the pet
bulls and the and the and the gas inside
and the pressure of the gas was used to
generate heat as opposed to work when i
add the pebbles back if i have friction
i'm not going to get back to the same
point that i was before because friction
is always resisting the movement so in
order for something to be reversible
when i remove a couple of pebbles if i
remove 10 pebbles and add the 10 valve
pebbles back i should be at the exact
same state but as you know you can just
do the thought experiment if there's
friction i won't be at the exact same
state
my my my
my piston won't move as much as you
would expect if it was frictionless so
this is key this is a key assumption for
reversibility
now the carnot cycle by definition is
reversible
it's reversible and that's why no one
could actually really implement an
engine that uh that that fully does the
carnot cycle and we even showed that
that the carnot cycle is the most
efficient potential engine that if
anyone made a more potential more
efficient engine you could have a a
perpetual motion machine or a perpetual
energy machine and the reason why the
carno engine is the most efficient
engine and there's no secret here is
because it's it's frictionless any
engineer who makes engines can tell you
wow if i could just remove all of the
friction from my system i'll be get i
would get a lot more efficient
now with that said so i've i've told you
that look this has the definition
doesn't have to be it happened to work q
divided by t because i was dealing with
a reversible system
and just to hit the point home let me
show you that it would not have worked
if i had just defined it q divided by t
on an irreversible system
so let's say that i have let me draw
another pv diagram
i have another pv diagram and i'm going
to do a very
almost a very
i would say a very simple thought
experiment
now i'm going to have an irreversible
system and i start here at some point on
my pv diagram
and you know this could be
a
some type of cylinder and it has a
piston on top and i have
my rocks like always but this time
there's a little bit of friction when
this thing moves a little bit of heat is
generated and this and when it moves in
either direction some heat is generated
so we can call that the heat from
friction when it moves either up
or when it moves down
so let's do something let's stick this
on a big reservoir like we tend to do so
it's an isothermal system so let's call
this
let's call this t1
and let's just start removing pebbles
let's just start removing pebbles and
we'll move along an isotherm
we'll move a nice along an isotherm
maybe
to that point there
and then we're going to and i want to
make a very important point here
because this is friction this has
friction
i'm not going to get quite as far along
the isotherm than if i if i didn't have
friction if this was a frictionless
system i would have gotten a little bit
further
along the isotherm so the number of
rocks isn't going to be the same as if
it was frictionless but let's just say i
move from here to here on the pv diagram
and then we go and add a bunch of rocks
back and we want to go all the way back
and i'm not even saying whether we have
the same number of rocks or different
rucks you're probably going to have to
add a few more rocks to get back to this
point but the idea here is is that we've
gotten back to the same point on the
state diagram so our delta
u total
should be
equal to zero
which is equal to the delta u of
expansion so the delta u of expansion is
the delta u to go that way delta u of
expansion
plus the delta u of contraction
which is the delta u of going back like
this
those have to be equal to
zero by definition
right because delta internal energy is
state variable if we get to that same
point our delta u has to be equal to
zero so what's our delta u of expansion
what's our what's our change in internal
energy as we expand
our delta u of expansion
is equal to
what's equal to the heat added to the
system
right it's equal to the heat added to
the system
minus the work done by the system
minus the work done by the system so
minus work done by the system and we
know how much work was done this whole
area right there
and then plus the heat added by the
friction
there's some heat added by the friction
let me do that in brown
plus some heat added by the friction
what's what's that
i was on some random website on the
others were off off the screen and all
of a sudden that cartoon sound started
up i didn't had no idea what that was
but anyway where was i so i said our our
change in internal energy from expansion
is going to be the heat added to the
system from our reservoir
minus the work done by the system by as
we expand
plus the heat added to the system or
generated by the system i guess you
could say it's not being added this is
the the system is creating this heat
itself as it expands there's this
friction right there fair enough so this
is this is the one variation when now
that we're not dealing with a reversal
process we have this friction now what's
our change in energy from contraction
so our change in internal energy from
contraction is going to be the heat that
is that is leaves the system that has to
go back into the reservoir as we
contract because otherwise if we didn't
have the reservoir the temperature would
go up but we want to release heat so we
want to say heat released and i'm going
to do something let's just assume that
all of the cues are positive so if i'm
releasing heat it's going to be a minus
minus q
release let's just say this is a
positive number and if i'm releasing it
it's going to be a minus right there and
i want to just do that just to make
hopefully make things a little bit
clearer
plus the work performed on the system
i'm assuming that work is always
positive so for doing work it'll be
minus work if work is being done to us
it'll be plus work
but in this situation as well we're
still adding heat from friction or heat
from friction is still being generated
in the system this is still positive
in either direction when we move upwards
or downwards the system is generating
friction now we always said we went all
the way here we went all the way back so
the sum of these has to be equal to 0
because it's just a state variable so if
the sum of the all of this has to be
equal to 0 let's sum this up so this
gets us to
q
a minus q r
so the heat accepted minus the heat
released
the w is cancelled out
plus
plus
let me see right here plus
2 times
the heat of friction in either direction
all of that has to be equal to zero
let's see we can what we can do is we
can we can rewrite this as the heat
accepted minus the heat released is
equal to
minus 2 times the amount of heat
generated from friction
and then if we just switch these around
we'll get the heat released
minus
the heat accepted is equal to well i
just wanted to get all positive numbers
2 times
the heat of friction now why did i do
all of this because i wanted to do an
experiment with a with an irreversible
system and this was a very simple
experiment with the irreversible system
now we said that delta s
delta s which
a long time ago i defined as q divided
by t and in this video i said it had to
be reversible i wanted to show you right
now that what if this is what if i
didn't make the if i didn't make the
constraint that this has to be
reversible because if this doesn't have
to be reversible and i just use this
definition right here
you'll see that
your delta s your delta s here would be
you just divide everything by t
you just divide everything by t because
our temperature was constant the entire
time we were just on a reservoir
you'll see that this this is you're
going to be your delta s
this is your total change in the
i guess you could say your net heat
added to the system so this is let me
say this is
this is the heat added to the system
let me do this way
heat
added to the system
divided by the temperature at which it
was added
divided by the temperature yeah exactly
divided by the temperature it was added
which is a positive number even though
we got to the exact same place on the
state diagram so in an irreversible
system this wouldn't be a valid state
variable so it's only a valid state
variable if it's reversible
now does that mean that you can only
talk about entropy for
for reversible reactions no you can talk
about entropy for anything but what you
do is and this is another important
point
so let's say that i have some
irreversible reaction
irreversible reaction that goes from
here
to here
and i want to figure out its change in
entropy right and it might have done all
sorts of crazy things it's an
irreversible reaction it its path might
have gone like that that's that's even
assuming it's quasi-static we can even
look at its path like that if we wanted
to figure out its change in entropy
though we wouldn't worry about the heat
that was added to it and the different
temperatures at which it was added we
wouldn't worry about that we would just
say okay what would have what would have
taken for a reversible system to go from
this state to this state
and then we maybe a reversible system
would have done something like this
sorry
i want to make it a smooth curve maybe a
reversible system might have done
something like that and that
and this change this heat added in the
by the reversible system divided by the
temperature for the reversible system
would be the change in entropy and this
change in entropy we could say call this
s final
sorry
s
final and this is
s initial it's going to be the same for
both systems it's just we don't use the
irreversible system to figure out our
entropy we would use the reversible heat
and temperature to figure out the actual
change hopefully that clarifies
something else it's on some level a
subtle point but on some level it's
super important because you can't the
thermodynamic definition of entropy has
to be this it has to be heat added to a
reversible system divided by the
temperature it was added not just heat
to any system it just happened to work
when i did it and i should have been
clear about it when i first explained it
that it that it worked only because it
was a carnot cycle which is which is
reversible